This is the most
I've ever seen. Tectone's kind of like a hero, if you think about
it. Like he's always standing up for the little guy. That's what
he's asking. Is it illegal to report? No, idiot. What the [__]
are you talking about?
>> Oh my god, what? YOU STUPID
>> WOAH!
HOLY [__]
GO. Now I got this I've got this Lea Salameanti tweet that looks
spicy. It looks pretty crazy. I don't know what it I'm kind of
interested to find out what it is. Check this out. Dude, at this
point I'm just waiting for the new Tectone allegations to drop.
His fiance His fiance has no pants on. She doesn't want to be
on stream and he doesn't understand the meaning of no when she
says no as she doesn't want to be on stream because she has no
pants on. Even his edgy chat is saying no means no. Bro, what?
It Does he get angry here? It looks like he gets angry.
What I haven't seen this clip yet. What is going on here? >> open
and then record the guy without his consent where he was naked.
HOLY
WHY ARE YOU SLAMMING THE DOOR LIKE THAT?
YOU SCARED THE [__] OUT OF ME.
DUDE, I Am I reading too much into this? Immediately I hear this
and I immediately think he's being performative for the stream
because he's angry at her. He The way he victimizes himself over
everything, it's a me My immediate thought is he's being super
performative for the stream and losing his [__] cuz
he's mad at her and he wants the stream to be mad at her.
Oh, hold up. I thought I was under
I was about to bring out my crossbow.
Hold up. You're giving me a stroke.
>> A crossbow?
What? This guy lives in What? North Carol No, I Where does he
live now? A crossbow?
>> Why doesn't he have guns? He's an American with the
second amendment >> Sorry. My arm is broken. Sorry for
>> Was he still in Texas? Right, right, >> Sorry
I called your mom. You're not a I apologize. That was just That
was a reactionary from a mild adrenaline exploding through my
body. Holy crap, that was so loud. That That literally sounded
Okay, 43 seconds. Was it that loud? >> open and then record
the guy without his consent where he was naked. HOLY
WHY ARE YOU SLAMMING THE DOOR
I MEAN, I I guess it seemed a little loud, but
I can't tell if it's his reaction or They're pulled back. Here
we go. >> literally sounded like a
Well, I I can't tell how loud it is depending on how the mic
set up. If you knew more about the mic set up, maybe it's loud,
maybe it's not loud.
No, no, no. I'm not blaming you. I'm saying, okay? It just sounded
like a Oh, hold on. No, that's a that's a wide It's What is it?
Not dynamic range. What is it called where it's not directional?
Yeah, it's a dynamic mic, right? Like it's picking up everything
in the room. That's why he could sit so far back and still talk.
So, that's not that loud. That would pick up the door just
>> Well, maybe get that door fixed. You know what's crazy?
You're also AN
>> You could also go get that door fixed. No, go ahead
get that You could [laughter] also just make the call while you're
sitting Look at you. You're not even WEARING YOU'RE YOU'RE NOT
EVEN WEARING PANTS. YOU'RE IN your slippers.
You're wearing my shirt. >> It's my shirt. Oh, I'm just
so busy. I can't make the call.
That is your shirt. That's a big ass shirt, not to be fair. You
can make the call. You can get it fixed. What Why do I Why do
I got to call him? I'm busy. Doing what? Sleeping?
Oh, okay. Are you Bro, I Dude, that's
That I That's already kind of troubled paradise, isn't it? This
This lazy This lazy
won't just do her job. We're a traditional family. She's got
to do the
>> Also, um there's a YouTube video that says that if you
ever would have my kids, you're going to end up a single mother
because Tectone's going to leave you and it has 40 views right
now. No. Why does he know about that? How in the world does he
know about a YouTube video that's got 40 views?
Are you serious? You sick
What is wrong with this guy? What the [__] is this
What is wrong with this guy, man? It's got 40 views. It says
you're going to be a single mom. Oh. I know. Oh my >> Yeah.
And you And you'll never And you'll never get Well, you know
what? I'm not going to Get him. I'm not going to tell
I don't know. Um but I'm not even going to let you guess what
their Twitter bio looks like. I'm not going to get you involved
in that, but their Twitter bio looks exactly about how you expect.
Yeah.
>> Um Anyways, thank you for the tea and water. Yeah, I
will say other than the first part that felt weird and this guy's
got his own weird [__] going on, this clip has not
quite delivered on him trying to force her onto stream yet. That
was just a clip. That was just a teaser. That's not the Tectone
crash out stuff. It's nothing like that. Okay, Tectone got into
a fight recently with Pirate Software, okay?
And it I don't I don't know how to describe it. It was a fight.
Tectone basically made some comments, okay? He made some comments
in his previous Pirate Software video. Okay, about the mods and
stuff and about whether or not Pirate Software pays his mod team.
This is what? 6 days ago? This is his reaction to the this guy
who does the Pirate Software log content. >> his moderators
full-time salaries often exceeding $60,000
annually. When Theo, right? Okay. What the [__] are
they doing to deserve $60,000?
Like what What are they doing? And do you have any proof of that?
No, Pirate Software does not pay
He grocked it. He grocked it. He grocked >> a flat $60,000
a year. He does pay them as full-time salaried employees with
benefits. Here's what's confirmed. He's incorporated business
specifically to employ his moderators full-time rather relying
on volunteers. His moderators are team full-time salary plus
benefits including medical, dental, vision, and life insurance.
He has mentioned having 12 moderators on full-time pay benefits
plus others. What do Pirate Software's
do to deserve
full-time [snorts] pay? I do think he's streamed enough that
like maybe there's some kind of argument. That many moderators
probably not. I'm guessing he was having them do other stuff.
>> normal mod stuff and he's paying
a year
to do normal mod stuff.
Hey guys, guys, guys.
Go mod for him.
Don't mod for me. This is the most
I've ever seen in my whole life. >> up. insanely
difficult work
that requires reliability, quick judgment, and emotional resilience.
>> Wait. Glazing the jannies is crazy, man. are we talking
about? Yo, Tectone, my paycheck and you pull on my Genji
this is
Like, okay, I pay my editors because they're working non [__]
stop. I give my editors 100% of the revenue after tax on my clip
channel. This is
Wait, is that you paying your editors?
There's no way he just said Now, maybe it's worth it or something.
I don't know. But is that really you paying your editors, Tectone?
This is a lie. There's no way. Is there any proof beyond Pirate
Software's word that he's paying his mods full-time salaries?
>> No. So, he's starting to He's starting to really doubt
it, okay? And he makes a prediction and he basically lays some
money out on the line. >> There is no proof beyond THEIR
WORDS BECAUSE IT I would anyone mod for free, though?
Akira, how much are the infamously generous
Well, how much is the infamously generous
Nick Lee compensating you for modding? Let me know. I don't know,
Akira, but I would love to know. How much? Cuz I know Nick Nick
is very generous. He pays very large salaries. >> IT'S
A LIE. HE DOESN'T MAKE THAT MUCH. Based off of his analytics,
off of his current stream time, and off of his current viewership,
he is making at most 80 to 90,000 dollars annually off of streaming
off of Twitch. He does not do it and I challenge Pirate Software
and I will give them 100 subs if I'm wrong. HE MAY HAVE done
this at a point. He no longer does this. There is no way he continues
to do this. This is a fraudulent claim. It is all Okay, I was
I was totally off. I I knew that Pirate Software had paid his
mods. I would say it's very unlikely to me that given the falloff
in viewership and monetary value, I I don't think Pirate Software
still pays the same amounts. And that must be very difficult
bordering on impossible, right? >> All for optics. He is
full of [__] This is not real. And if I'm wrong,
I will give them No, not 100 I'll give them 200 subs. I challenge
one of his moderators to show me that you've received consistent
full-time pay over the past four years. Let's say it. This is
a lie and the over the past four years. Now, Tectone calls him
out, okay? And then eventually we get to a whole back and forth
on Twitter about it. Okay, so Pirate Software Pirate Software
calls him out. We'll go to this thread right here, okay? So,
Sneaky Leaf posts this clip and says, "Tectone states the full
criteria Pirate Software needs to prove for Tectone to pay up
and retract the claims he made about moderators not being paid
60K or he could go to Tectone in DMs." So, this is a follow-up
from Tectone on a later stream, okay? >> not that deep.
It's really not. But But once again, if Pirate Software shows
that he's paying what and at very specific 12 different
full-time salary which is
annually and you show me the past 6 months. So, and I'll make
it I'm going to write this out very clear.
I'm going to write this out very clear so that way this can I
love that he's totally moved well 44,000 I'm guessing that's
minimum wage for what's considered full-time employment. But
realistically he's just wrong for doubting this if Pirate Software
was paying them a consistent wage like and benefits for that
long for like a couple years, he's just wrong to even try to
point this out. He looks stupid. >> K. Let's keep watching.
K? 12
different
right? 12 different mods
Okay. 6
months
prior to now.
Minimum like
30k? I'm guessing he grocked this to find out what minimum minimum
wage full-time employment looks like and it would depend on state.
These are the three.
Thor, I got I got no issues with you at all. I got no desire
to have issues with you at all. But the problem is is that when
you're messing with mods and making them feel like they're being
taken advantage of, that annoys the [__] out of me.
So
Tectone's such a good guy. Tectone's kind of like a hero if you
think about it. Like he's always standing up for the little guy.
When he
orally his ex-girlfriend, that was for the little guy, okay?
That was for the incel in his community knowing that they'll
never be with a woman. He is a hero when he does things like
that. Is he not, guys? That's why he did it. To stand up for
the little man who will never get an attractive woman in their
>> Let's make it very clear. Let's make it >> Let's
just Let's just write it out.
Feb
January, [laughter]
October. There is no way you're paying them that much. There's
no And once again, and I will honor my word, $10,000,
K? If all of these are met
to Maya.
It's It's really that easy. Wait, why 10k to Maya to all this?
He says that like Alveus he'll donate to. Like bro, donate to
Pirate Software's ferret sanctuary, man. What the Why you donating
to Maya? Why you simping for Maya, man? Oh, Pirate chose Alveus?
Okay, I got it. I got it. I got it. >> I will absolutely
do that. 10k to Maya.
10k to Maya if all those are hit. I
absolutely
a Yeah, I think I'm missing the part where Pirate first responds.
But he does respond, okay? 100%.
If you actually do I'm a man of my word. I don't lie. I I honor
myself and not like I would love to give $10,000 to charity,
especially if I'm wrong. And if you do that, God bless your soul.
Are you on food stamps? How are you affording to eat? It's I
wrote it all out. You hit all those, you have the paper right
there, you prove that's what you're doing, it's really that easy.
K? No redactions, none of this Epstein file.
But or or if you want, Pirate, you can DM me. I will not disclose
that you DM'd Just say, "Hey, I want to move forward from this.
Can you drop it and I'll never mention it again." It's really
that easy. I thought this was a very easy yeah, you're right.
I don't do that. Sorry, I don't know how that information got
put out there.
>> I just kind of assumed I was right, you >> Now
we're doubling down on this [__] Pirate I got I got
no interest in doing the back and forth. Straight up. There are
way worse people on the internet than you. I I don't care about
this [__] But like let's be dead ass here.
Your files were more redacted than the
So, anyways, hit those qualifications if you want 10k. If not,
you can DM me privately. I won't say
Pirate Software had shown some stuff,
So, he showed it live on his stream. This is what he showed and
he just had things like redacted a little bit. But apparently
he's shown on his stream before a bunch of other stuff.
Anyway, we continue on. We continue >> forward. It is what
it is. I genuinely just want moderators to not think and have
un- unrealistic
expectations for what they're going to get paid.
>> Because that makes no sense. Because the majority of
mods just do it for the love of the game because there's not
really that much to do for a lot of chats. Maybe if you're like
a KaiCenat mod or you're like a head mod that manages all the
other mods and like plans content and helps editors and coordinates
editors and da da da da da da da da But like some guy going ban
maybe once every like three streams, $60,000
that is insane.
Anyways, bye-bye. Yeah, I I agree that a full-time salary for
every one of your Twitch mods or Kick that seems unreasonable,
obviously. Now, he's paid a couple people this apparently. It's
really not that Oh, hold on. I'll be gracious. Over the last
6 months >> Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah. This is This is going
to be in this one, okay?
Here's my proof with unredacted amounts. What is this? First
statement here is from Gusto showing that I was completing all
of these payments
to the number of US staff that we had. These are the totals over
on the side. Usually around 30 to $32,000 for US staff. These
here are wire transfers going to each one of the different staff
members for those based on their role, based on the pay that
they get. Um some of them are part-time so those values are less
and you can see these going all the way back to October which
was the requirement of I mean this guy pays a lot out in salary.
I Tectone has to admit that he's totally owned on this point.
Like I'm sorry, even if he's not paying quite as much as you
thought
he is absolutely paying out a [__] money to his staff.
Now one question people had is are these all of your employees
for your business? Are these like your mods at all? Do you Do
we know that any of these people are actually mods?
Cuz he does have technically like a game studio. He was technically
paying somebody to work on his game I think for a little bit.
So, are these people actually his mods like his Twitch mods?
>> 6 months. This can go all the way back to I
I stated before May of 2024. My content blew up on December 2023.
I started paying my staff in May of 2024 because I didn't want
to do it too soon because I was worried that it wouldn't last.
That actually makes perfect sense. How many people is that? He
said Well, he showed the other documentation he showed was six
people. >> Oh, first 32,000
So, these This is some sort of HR software, regular six employees.
He's paying out $30,000 a month. You divide that, the average
is five get five grand each a month. That's $60,000 a year.
Didn't he purge a bunch of mods recently? I don't think he purged
them. I think a lot of them left. He had like a a mutiny of sorts.
Okay? So, yep. Showed this live on stream. Staff at my studio
are paid between 60 and 120,000 dollars a year depending on the
role. I let a number of people go in a layoff recently and many
staff over the last year in a drawdown. After this, two staff
members resigned. I make less as a creator than I did a year
ago and needed to do this to keep things afloat. The staff are
not to blame and should be left alone. The pictures below show
payments over in Gusto in white and wire wire transfers in black.
Over Gusto in white. So, I'm guessing this is some kind of HR
Wire transfers in black. Names and account numbers have been
redacted from the screenshots. You wanted 6 months and this should
cover that. Tectone, you can make the check out to Alveus Sanctuary
which is run by Maya Higa if you decide to follow through on
paying charity. What they do is fantastic.
W- W- W- W- W- Wow. Amazing. Okay, so we have Tectone's full
response right here.
backs up Pirate Software in the job about mod pay says he's misunderstood.
I don't think that Pirate lied. I think Pirate paid his mods.
I think that mods just got mad and brought the hate the hate
videos and they
turned against him on his own. You can
>> I didn't get this clip.
Sided with Pirate Software? Oh, no. >> Pirate is just misunderstood.
Okay, so I want to make it very clear. I'll make it very clear.
I also thought that Pirate Software is drastically misunderstood.
But I'm sorry.
To my knowledge and we're going to look into this I was told
that Pirate Software pays all of his mods $60,000
and he has 12 mods that he pays $60,000
to. And I want to I want to show you
Does Pirate
Software pay
his mods $60,000
Is he searching the same thing in Grok again? dollars salary
every year?
I Grok said no. Yeah, I get I get that you asked Grok and Grok
said no. If that's not the flat amount but he does pay them full
salary and benefits. That's what Grok said for the first
He's going to get like fooled by the first line of of the first
line, right?
No, there's actually Matt, you you don't even know. This is the
second time he's asking Grok. The first time he asked it said
no. He does pay them full-time salary and benefits but not $60,000.
This is a different clip, yes.
Am I crazy or did this say yes, he said that last time?
No, you're wrong. We literally just looked at it. We literally
just looked at you looking at this
Yeah, where was it where he says,
Goes and does the the math here. Where does he Grok it? I saw
him Grok it
Right there. Oh, hold on. Hold on. We got to go back even further.
Even
No, Pirate Software does not pay his moderators a flat $60,000
a year. When he looked at looked it up before, Grok gave him
the same answer. No, he does not pay $60,000 a year. He does
pay full-time salaried employees with benefits or he does give
his full-time salaried employees benefits. This is the same answer
I gave before.
Why would he do this to himself? What it this is just a crash
out. Like he just
He's already doing something bad by the way. You looking this
up in Grok is stupid to begin with. But even then, he's not even
doing a good job of using this as a source of The 60K figure
comes from critics like TechTone down the claim or challenging
him. PirateSoftware hasn't publicly specified an exact salary
like
Um he's just taking Pirate's word for it. But Pirate No, no,
no. Pirate showed this stuff. This is old, isn't it? Oh, no,
this one's new. But Pirate I believe had showed stuff like this
months ago.
I thought he did. And also none of his mods came out and said
he lied. I don't think his mods even really suggested that he
lied before.
I've never really seen a mod say No, no, no, nobody got paid
ever.
He is his source? Yeah, but this is like actual documentation
from his HR software. What do you mean? Yeah, he's his source.
He's the only one who would have this. What other information
are you expecting? Is the old Asmongold clip? I mean, we just
watched Asmongold take PirateSoftware's side, right?
WHAT WAS THIS? WAS THIS NOT DID DID GROK NOT say that last time?
I SWEAR TO GOD.
IT DID NOT.
DID I I SWEAR TO GOD I saw it. In short, he does pay his mods
proper salaries, benefits uncommon for Twitch, which he frames
as a point of pride, but the specific $60,000 every year isn't
directly verified from him. It's more of a skeptical benchmark
used in community debates. Sustainability was always questioned
given stream revenue. That's what I also said. Uh TechTone with
the misinformation. Actually, it was not me with the misinformation.
It was actually Sarah.
It was actually Sarah of the lake who came in here and said that
PirateSoftware pays his mods 60,000 Put his mods under the bus.
>> I remember that specifically because I saw Sarah who
used to be one of my mods come in here and say that PirateSoftware
pays their mods $60,000
each. And so then I said, "Really?" And
This Is guy drinking a protein shake out of like a jar mug?
So weird, man. Just get a shaker cup, dog. Hey, I've watched
him I He's used shaker cups before. Why the [__]
is Why are you using this cup for like a protein shake? I assume
that's a protein shake. Ice coffee.
Okay, maybe it's a little better if it's an ice coffee. Okay,
maybe I can forgive >> Then I Grok'd it and then Grok confirmed
Uh let me look this up. Uh I don't mind the mason mug. If you
were to like mix a protein shake and then put it in a mason mug,
you're a weirdo. >> this checking this video. Okay, is
there is there any Grok'ing in here? Yeah, there is and you Grok'd
it and you're you're dummy.
He does pay them with full-time salary with benefits.
So it's the same thing again. Where the [__] did
this Where did Sarah get this $60,000 number from?
Where did you get it from? YOU'RE THE STREAMER WHO RAN with it.
Where did you get it from, TechTone? That's the question.
That that Could you imagine like a chatter tells you something
wrong and you totally run with it? You you call people out on
it.
And then you find out that chatter's lying. You just didn't do
any groundwork. In fact, the groundwork you did said that chatter
was wrong. >> Is what it said? Cuz right there I check
where I Grok'd it and it's changed. Sarah, where did you get
this $60,000 number from? Trying to blame somebody else for him
being totally wrong?
Cuz like obviously when like, you know, I mean Sarah, you were
like one of my most trusted mods back in the day. It's like when
you come in here saying that like, you know, other mods are getting
paid [__] it. We go to the next part. >> factual
information that I can PirateSoftware is going to read The PirateSoftware
post we just read. I have no interest in hating this guy. I really
don't care, right? When the whole OnlyFans drama came out and
tell me that I'm lying, I was his biggest defender writing every
single wrong that people were saying about him. I held him accountable
and then he ceased communication. It was a little weird. I'm
not going to lie,
Uh-huh. The blowup started in December 2023 and payment started
in May 2024. We used wire transfers originally and then ADP and
now Gusto for US payroll. Wire transfers were still used for
EU contractors throughout. All USA mods were on payroll and all
EU mods on contract. I even gave them bonuses on Christmas. Where
is my 200 subs and retraction of your false claim? Okay, now
let's see. I haven't seen these yet. So let's see how much he's
paying them. How is he How is he going to cope now? What? Of
course, you can't even make it up. Of course, TechTone has no
idea how to perceive or deal with or interpret actual paystub
data coming from an actual program employers use. Of course.
Dude, he
Dude, this is Listen, he looks at this [__] or like
a job application. That [__] is hieroglyphics to
him. You might as well put him in ancient Egypt. He can't read
[__] What the [__] is it? Monthly off-cycle
bracket? What is this stuff? Payroll? What?
Every single person recognizes ADP. I I defy you to find somebody
who has done anything even remotely tech adjacent who has not
gotten paid through ADP at some point in their life.
If you are a part If you're a part of any corporation, any company
that works in tech at all, you've either moved to ADP or off
of ADP, okay?
Every single person. Bro, these are more redacted than the Epstein
files. The fact that he has the this information at all, I do
get that it's a a bit over redacted here and he unredacts a little
bit more of that recently or when he went over it on
right? But like dude, the fact that he can even pull this stuff
up is speak like you lost. You just totally lost. Why would you
even pretend otherwise? dollars for you. Oh, whoops. I don't
even want to play this. We need to keep keep going back TO THIS.
WHAT THE [__] WAS THIS EVEN SUPPOSED TO
LIKE WHAT OH, WAIT, REALLY? ADP is statistically likely to pay
you, which is why they provide the unofficial jobs data. I didn't
even know that was how widespread they are. That's crazy.
Like they could give They could basically compete with the US
Census
That's nuts, MAN. >> WHAT WHAT IS THIS?
I ALSO say the past 6 months and only one of your screenshots
has the past 6 months. Brother brother. So hold on, that is this
screenshot, right? Regular six employees, past 6
Yeah, I mean he hasn't done payroll for May yet, but he has been
paying out roughly equivalent amounts the whole
That's the past 6 months. That's the kill shot right there. Problem
is it's how much you're saying and there is no way that you were
paying anywhere near that amount. You just You don't have that
money. Now, once again, if you are to show all and you have to
show all 12 employees that they're getting paid, I would prefer
the past 4 years, but you can do the past 6 months and you can
show me that these are real because you've lied about other things,
I would love to give you 200 subs. I would love to retract the
false claims cuz I don't want to go after people over lies. I
have no interest in doing that, for real. I have PirateSoftware.
I have no interest in harming you. I have no interest in going
after you over [__] that's lies because there's already
enough real bad people, but there The problem is is that when
it exists that Oh, PirateSoftware only has this many
Oh god, he's so dumb. Oh, no. Hold on. I don't think PirateSoftware
was super confusing here, okay? So TechTone doesn't like this.
Here, hold on. Hold on. Be very happy to donate to Alveus if
I'm wrong, but the phrases you're using, staff at my studio is
very confusing to me and I believe to be deceptive language.
No, when he's talking about staff at his studio, he's saying
they make more money. He's saying they make 60 to 120 grand a
year. Yeah, I believe he was saying that for some of those people
they're not staff They're not studio people or they're not staff
at the studio at all, right? Like he he makes a differentiation.
Let's watch it one more time. >> statement here is from
Gusto showing that I was completing all of these payments to
the number of US staff that we had. These are the totals over
in the side. Usually around 30 to $32,000 for US staff. These
here are wire transfers going to each one of the different staff
members for those based on their role, based on the pay that
they get. Um some of them are part-time so those values are less
and you can see these going all the way Now, I don't see how
these people could possibly be for his like studio for like the
PirateSoftware [__] Cuz I've not seen anything produced
from them that's interesting or good. >> way back to October,
which was the requirement of 6 months. This can go all the way
back to I
I stated before May of 2024. My content blew up on December 2023.
I started paying my staff I feel free to link it easy. 2024 because
I didn't want to do it too soon because I was worried that it
wouldn't last.
So he said recently that he did he did have to lay people off.
Like he said he had to lay people off recently because the stream
doesn't make as much money. That makes total sense that you'd
have to lay people off.
Hey, we continue. And his moderators getting paid $60,000
full-time salary with benefits from Seattle, a place where the
minimum wage is like $23.
Why would you assume that it's in
Does he think that Does he think that you're beholden to like
the minimum wage where you're incorporated if you're hiring people?
I don't think that's the case. You hire somebody in India, you
don't have to pay them the minimum wage in Seattle. That's [__]
stupid That would make no sense whatsoever. Well, it would make
sense, but it also
it also
would totally [__] over a ton of American companies.
It is not the case. >> That's just literally impossible
and the problem is you're making people's moderators feel undervalued,
underappreciated, and I'm sorry, you can't just say, "Oh, well,
see, look, there's payments right here. Just look." Okay, well,
how much is that? 100 bucks? 200 bucks? 300 bucks? Because I
guarantee you this number, which should be somewhere in the ballpark
of $4,000,
ain't there. There's
>> Oh, IT'S THERE, THOUGH. IT'S THERE, THOUGH. It's been
there the whole time. Now, let's keep going here, and let's see
what Pirate said.
Tectone's not giving you 200 subs. They changed it now to 10K
to charity of your choice after realizing you could could actually
prove it.
Why? Why would I be afraid of giving him
Uh thanks for the raid. That That means Why is it bad that I
would pay 10 times more to charity? And also, that did I I didn't
I wasn't really listening to Thor when he talked. >> Tectone's
not giving you 200 subs. They changed it now to 10K to charity
of your choice after realizing you could could actually prove
it. Uh wait, I think
Well, one, he's reading How does Tectone really like not acknowledge
that he's reading a chat message? Why would I be afraid of giving
him
What That That means I Why is it bad that I would pay 10 times
more to charity?
And also, that didn't change at all.
It was from the same video.
It was the same video. If you watch the video, you would see
that. But the reality is is that it just needs to be cleared
up that he's not paying his moderators 60,000 or 44,000
a year. There's no way he does that.
If they want to give Well, I'm guessing the moderators do other
stuff, like do community events and keeps running, right? I'm
guessing it's not just for moderating the Twitch chat. If that's
all Tectone's driving at, yeah, I'm guessing these people do
other things.
10K to charity. Have them give that charity to Maya Higa. 100%.
Give the $10,000 to Alveus Sanctuary. Make it public. Sure. And
I'm I'm cool with that. If that's the outcome of that.
Pirate Pirate actually making smart moves. Pirate looks like
a very gracious person there. That does a lot to buy back a little
bit of goodwill, doesn't it? That he's going to say, "Okay, just
go donate to Maya Higa. Go donate to Maya. Go to Go to Go donate
to an animal sanctuary." >> Once again, I'm I'm absolutely
down, but I just feel like there's just no way you're paying
your moderators $44,000 a year. There's no way. There's absolutely
no way. Hands down, man. What is going on with that? Tectone
made a claim that I never paid any of the moderators. He put
two No. No.
I did not say [laughter] that.
What I said was you may be paying your moderators, but you're
not paying them
a year. That is what I said. I said you are not paying them $60,000.
I I I Okay. I literally showed the clip. I I don't know what
it is if you're watching, but that claim was not made. >> Okay,
bro. >> 100 subs on the line, and apparently the claim
now It's not even that he's moving the goalpost. It's like technically
that is what he said verbatim, but the sentiment of what he's
communicating and all this is, "Oh, you're you're way overpaying
these people. You never do that." And I think Pirate was like
overpaying them, but he wanted to make it so that like all of
his people had some form of way to make money, right? Like some
form of security.
Honestly, if he just gave them benefits, if he just if he just
paid for like an insurance benefits package for all of those
people, that would be above and beyond to me. But Tectone is
is trying to act like, "Oh, well, no, it was just the amount.
The The crazy The crazy thing was the amount, not that he was
paying them at >> Now is that he would give $10,000 to
charity if there was proof. I posted proof on Twitter immediately
and showed all of our receipts from the last since
And if the claim is that he will be paying $10,000 to charity,
I want him to give it to Maya Higa and Alveus
No, that's not the claim. The claim was very clearly, and I will
play it again.
I I will play it again. The >> I think he did say 60,000,
but he made that number up in the first place. So, if it's just
like Like
It's like you made it You totally made a number up that was over
whatever he would have paid.
And then when he's like, "No, I did pay all of these people,
and they got benefits or whatever."
You're going, "Well, I said 60,000, and we got to stick to that
number." Well, you made that number up. >> The claim is
this. Because now Now you're drop
Those 30K amounts were over 6 months, right? They were. It was
30,000 to six people, so it's about $5,000 a month each. Which
would be ultimately $60,000 anyway. I'm sure there's some developers
for his game studio in there at some point cuz some of them were
making like $10,000 a month. Give me the timestamp for where
Tectone melts down on a chatter. That's PE content. I do not
rile. Send that in my way. Tectone crashes out on a viewer that
gave him money. this out. Yo, moderators, can you do me a favor?
Whenever somebody donates a couple dollars and gives me a message,
can you just relay what that is to me in mod chat in case I forget
it because when people start complaining about me not noticing
them in donations, it annoys the out of me. So, if somebody says
something that I need to hear, can you just copy what it is and
post it in mod general and just ping it to me? Cuz this Donald
Trump >> This this message that I just got from Agag saying
forgotten again dot It's It's just It's just cringe. It is. So,
just thanks. I just I don't feel like somebody having a panic
attack in chat. Thanks, man. Such a victim, man. Such a victim.
This guy is so This guy is just an He's just cringe. He donated
money to me, and then he asked me to like acknowledge it. So
cringe, man. So cringe. You're basically a [__] as
a Also, do me a favor, Agag. Send me your PayPal. I'm I'm going
to refund you however much money you sent me. Just Mods, can
you give me this guy's PayPal? I'm I'm going to refund them all
their money, okay? I just I just don't want to hear about it.
It's It's annoying as Dude, there's no What a
And now I am saying it not in a misogynistic way cuz it's about
a man. What a total
Holy [__] Can't even refund some dude by himself,
by the way. He has to refund it. Mods, can you give me his PayPal?
Can you give me his email? Mods, can you do some work? Mods,
can you do some Shut up, man.
Shut the up.
How about you just be thankful for people giving you money?
You're like incredibly blessed that you get free money for people
for nothing but your stupid opinions. Trust me, it's not based
on merit.
You found a whole bunch of losers who are totally susceptible
to this victim act, and you milk money out of them. And instead
of being thankful for that, you want to when they don't treat
you like enough of a victim, enough of like a soft little baby
that just gets everything and gives nothing back.
Why? This guy sucks so bad. I should have every one of this guy's
viewers, okay? In a just world, I'd have every one of this guy's
viewers right now. Give me all of them. >> [__]
Thanks. Competition. Uh yeah, all right. Agag >> going
to They're not going to flourish under Tectone. What do you want?
Oh god, he's talking to him directly. I I I will sit right here.
Agag, what the [__] do you want? You to like read
a donation and/or acknowledge it on stream and say thank you.
I don't know.
None of my mods know.
Like, what Bro, I hope I hope I never do that. I can understand
if he's in the middle of like an epic rant or something and somebody,
you know, donated. I've I've bordered on getting annoyed with
Raven Ruben when I'm in the middle of ranting.
But that's mostly me saying, "Hey, I'm I It's my fault, man.
It's my fault that I'm ranting and I don't want to hear a donation
right now, so I shut it off for a second." Then I'm like, "I'm
sorry that I didn't play that." And I go back and I'll read it
after, okay? That's the closest I've ever gotten anything like
this. It's crazy. Just be thankful people are giving you money,
dude. >> What do you want? I'm sorry for ignoring you,
Tectone. Okay, you stupid
What do you want?
>> Oh my god, what? You stupid Whoa.
Holy [__]
What do you want? Guys go crazy, man. >> is, "Do you read
these? Can I do a huge favor? Forgotten again. You forgot something."
Just say it, you stupid
Just say it.
>> What do you want? For you to acknowledge the donations,
obviously. That he's donating money to you.
He wants an acknowledgement, a thank He said it multiple times.
Hello? Just type in chat. I don't need your money. Just type.
What a weirdo, man.
This guy's kind of weird. >> You want to know why?
You want to know why? Okay, it's simple cuz you don't want to
say yes to Agag. She'll know what it means. No, mods, ban
Mods, ban this guy. Ban him. Give me his PayPal. I'm refunding
all of the donations you gave me. I don't want it.
Okay? Wow. >> Ban him. Give me his PayPal.
As a matter of fact, I'm going to give you double
Vito moments, okay? No. You should be thankful for people who
donate. of what you donated to me to never come to any of my
content ever again. I'm good.
Weird as [__]
Like, okay, by the way, but Oh my god, dude, that [__]
is so annoying. Like
When people come in here and they donate money and they say,
"Do you read these?" How How you just ask the question?
And then That is a question.
And you're being blessed. One, he donates to say, "Do you read
these?" And you get to go, "Yes, I do." And then you get to wait
so that he can ask another question with a donation. He's giving
you money twice.
What the [__] you talking about, man?
He's doubling up for you. You get two donations. Isn't that awesome?
>> And all of that was because you wanted me to talk to
another streamer for you?
And then the worst thing is, people will clip this and then put
it on Twitter saying, "Teck Tone crashes out on a viewer that
gave him money."
>> Oh, let's
Thank you. You titled my clip for me, Tecky. Thank you. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you. Teck Tone crashes out on a viewer
that gave him money.
>> saying, "Teck Tone crashes out on a viewer that gave
him money."
So good. >> Like So good. I didn't even want it and I'm
refunding him.
Yo, Tecky, do you do things on stream? Why do people donate money
to say, "Will you read a question if I ask it?" Why not just
ask the question? Okay, now I I I I need you guys to honestly
understand like They're literally giving you a chance to make
double the money.
Uh Teck Tone must be way more set for life than I thought. He
must just be like done, done making money.
I don't even get it, man. Do you guys get why that's self-annoying?
I bet that was a schizo that got banned in her chat. I can absolutely
100%
confirm that. Thanks. Is it illegal to accuse someone of
assault? Watch. Ah. Watch.
No. It Oh my god.
I accuse Grock of assault on Teck Tone right now in this exact
moment in time. Dude, that's crazy.
Oh my god. Oh my god.
No. It Oh my god.
I mean, to begin with, the question What is the question?
Is it illegal to accuse someone of assault? So, it's In Teck
Tone's world, it's illegal to report rape. That's what he's asking.
Is it illegal to report rape?
No, idiot.
What the [__] are you talking about?
Oh my god.
No. It is not illegal to accuse someone of assault in general.
People have the right to report what they believe happened to
the police, in civil claims, to employers, schools, or publicly,
as long as the accusation is made in good faith. Okay, good.
That That gave me publicly as well. Thank you. Thank you. Thank
you.
Free speech protections and the ability to seek justice for crime
that simply making an accusation,
even a serious one, does not automatically violate the law. Now,
crash out about people who victims of assault being able to report
the crimes against them. Crash out about it. Crash out about
reporting being legal, please. That's all I need to make my whole
week, Teck Tone, is you crashing out about reporting being legal.
Thank you. Please I need it. I need it. I need it. Keep crashing
Brother. Brother. What? Here we go. If the accusation
What? knowingly false. You know it didn't happen, but say it
anyways. Let's Let's Google this. She didn't break [laughter]
in. She just stood at the door. No.
I need different AI. I need better AI. I need MRA. I need men
men's rights advocate AI, okay? I Grock, you're too
Grock, you're way too woke. >> The door was cracked open.
She pushed it open and then record the guy without his consent
where he was naked. HOLY
WHY YOU SLAMMING THE DOOR LIKE THAT?
YOU SCARED THE [__] OUT OF ME.
DUDE, he was tilted. He was tilted.
Are these How close are these together?
How close are they together? I need a timer or something.
I feel like he was already tilted from
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I feel like he was already in a mood
because of what Grock had told him. Grock was like, "No. No.
No. It's perfectly perfectly okay for somebody to report their
He was like, "What?" Dude. [snorts] Oh, hold up. I thought I
was under attack. No shot this guy. I was about to bring out
my crossbow. Obviously, you're not.